President Trump appeared to make light
of Russian efforts to meddle in the 2016
US election during a meeting with
Russian President Vladimir Putin at the
g20 summit Putin is one of the five
world leaders who have met with mr.
Trump in Japan so far
Paula Reid is in Osaka with more on this
story at Paula I guess a big question is
what did mr. Trump have to say to mr.
Putin in their first formal face-to-face
meeting in I guess nearly a year now
that's right Gail well the president
kicked off this meeting by saying he
believes very positive things will come
from this relationship
he was then asked though would he bring
up election interference he smiled
turned to the Russian leader told him
not to meddle but Vladimir Putin just
laughed as President Trump and his
Russian counterpart prepared for their
first meeting since the end of the
Muller investigation was a lot of
different things a reporter asked if he
would deliver Putin a 2020 election
warning
[Music]
while the president seemed to make light
of the situation
Muller's report was clear Russia
launched a systemic operation to
influence the 2016 election in trumps
favor Russian intelligence officers who
were part of the Russian military
launched a concerted attack on our
political system the two men last met
face to face nearly a year ago when
President Trump sided with Putin over
the u.s. intelligence assessment of
election interference
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be even as he
met with other world leaders to discuss
Iran trade and disarmament President
Trump kept an eye on his Democratic
rivals back home they have a debate
going on to had the first debate last
night perhaps you saw it wasn't very
exciting during his meeting with
Vladimir Putin the president was invited
to attend a world war 2 commemoration
next year in Russia the White House says
it has not made a decision on that
invitation just yet
Tony Paul the read for us in Japan Paula
thank you very much